do you dream in tweets that the question
yeah what is the black lives matter
movement if you had to make an elevator
pitch to an ignorant society the
movement began in Ferguson August 2014
it's focused on a new police violence
state violence and I'm doing the impact
of the legacy of racism in this country
and what's beautiful about it it's led
by people from all across the country
young people who've risen up and are
working to in structural and
institutional racism I saw you on
Colbert I mean you were talking to him
about white privilege how would you
define it and I think about white
privilege it is an understanding that
white is normative why is the standard
and that that confers with this so many
benefits that we think Oh what does it
mean have a band a that's skin color
it's not my skin it is someone else's so
we when we talk all the pros we talk
about these things that are unearned by
individuals but benefits that are
conferred by society do you think
reverse racism is a thing no tell me you
know racism is about power and racism is
up the excess has a power to
disadvantage people because of race and
when we think about reverse racism it is
suggested that that people of color
people without power are disadvantaging
white people people with power and that
that is that cannot happen racism itself
at its core is about the use of power to
oppress or to damage or a negative
exercise of power in people without
power can I be racist some of the
tactics that activists have taken up in
the black lives matter movement like
shutting down the bay bridge for example
recently here in the Bay Area have been
criticized by a lot of people haven't
seen as inconvenient by a lot of people
what's your response to that you know I
think often that that they're convenient
over time that they will be able to
drive across that bridge another day
that
you'll be able to go home quickly
another day and I think about Tamir rice
who will never go home again I think
about Mike Brown who will never go home
again I think about it Aiyana Jones and
Pearlie in Tremont and so many other
people who will never go home again so
that is what I think it's an election
season when you look at the candidates
right now what are you thinking yes I'm
not I'm not supporting anybody when I
think about Bernie Sanders I think that
his platform is a broad-ranging covers a
host of issues of the question that
remains with him as hot as he plan to
implement them and in what is he
prioritizing we think Oh Hillary she has
gone deep on a few issues and has not
covered a whole range of issues she
needs to have a more expansive platform
if she is going to adequately address
issues of criminal justice things
neither have addressed issues of the
racial wealth gap and they need to so
that is how I think of them I think
O'Malley needs to help us understand how
is zero tolerance policing strategy as
mayor Baltimore reconciles with his now
seemingly progressive platform at the
presidential level because he watched
the wire and then he thought back and
you're like oh not that ever